What does justice really mean?
Do those in law enforcement have a responsibility
to behave more ethically than the average
citizen?
These are the big questions at the forefront
of the latest psychological thriller making
waves on HBO Max - The Little Things.
The film stars a trio of Academy Award winners
as deputy sheriff Joe Deacon, played by Denzel
Washington, gets wrapped up in a Los Angeles
crime investigation with detective Jimmy Baxter,
played by Rami Malek , taking the lead.
There's a serial killer on the loose, and
both men obsess over figuring out who's behind
these deadly attacks.
Their search brings them to an outcast by
the name of Albert Sparma, played by Jared
Leto , who seems to fit the profile, but when
it comes to solving a case as messy as this
one, not everything is as it seems.
The Little Things is one of the first movies
subject to the bold new release strategy from
Warner Bros. that sees films debuting simultaneously
in theaters and on HBO Max.
The radical distribution plan is designed
to sidestep issues created by the ongoing
COVID-19 pandemic.
As such, there's a lot riding on the film's
success.
Even though we may not have any official numbers
on how well the film has done on the streaming
platform as of this video, it seems to have
caught on with audiences.
Don't worry - we won't spoil the ending for
you here.
"No, don't say anything, no spoilers!"
The response from professional critics has
been decidedly mixed on The Little Things,
according to Rotten Tomatoes.
So far, it's garnered a 48% critical score,
which is a bit shy of fresh, but it's doing
a lot better when you look at what general
audiences have to say.
By audience metrics, it has a rating of 64%
with over 250 reviews accumulated.
The general consensus among audience members
is that the three leads — Washington, Malek,
and Leto — are phenomenal in this film,
and really give it their all.
One of the verified audience reviews praises
Leto's work in this:
"The acting was fantastic.
I never [thought] Jared Leto could be this
creepy!!
It had some really suspenseful moments."
Leto has stated that he drew inspiration for
this role from a surprising world leader:
North Korean dictator Kim Jong-un.
The results are suitably creepy and entertaining.
As any good psychological thriller should,
The Little Things has a way of burrowing into
your mind and making you rethink everything
you've seen in the film.
One reviewer by the name of Farlisa writes,
"This is a mind twisted movie.
My husband and I are still replaying the events
in our heads."
With other comments like, quote, "Movie is
a must see" and "Unexpected ending but still
exciting and worth the watch," it's clear
this film, while perhaps divisive, is likely
worth a watch if you're a fan of thrillers.
In the event you're still on the fence about
whether or not to give The Little Things a
chance, then perhaps it's prudent to compare
it to a different thriller held in high regard
— Seven.
The 1995 neo-noir starring Morgan Freeman,
Brad Pitt, and Gwyneth Paltrow is one of director
David Fincher's best films, both due to the
moody atmosphere it creates as well as the
shocking ending that still terrifies audiences
to this day.
A lot of people over on Twitter are comparing
the classic 90s film with The Little Things
with @Gameoverluke writing,
"If you liked Seven then watch The Little
Things!
Such a good movie."
Regardless of people's opinions on the film
overall, one thing is clear — people love
Denzel Washington in this, and pretty much
any other movie he's in.
After all, it's not a coincidence that you
see comments like "Denzel is the best actor
of my time" and "Denzel Washington is still
the GOAT" among the fan reviews.
As with any movie, it's best to watch it for
yourself to form your own opinion.
You can check it out on HBO Max until the
end of February.
If one thing's clear from all of this, it's
that you don't want to be left out of the
conversation.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
new movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.